We're close to their territory. I'd
better be a little prepared. If they notice, it won't be too much of a hassle. I see, that's what
stopping the river is like.
Stop the boat. It'll create a fog, too. I understand, but we
have to do something like this.  If you leave it alone, you'll leave it alone.
[Music] If you leave it alone, it'll go away. [Music] Let's
break it to goblins and steal the weapons. It's
possible that they trained
here. Hey, you can't use fire here, but you
have to do housework.  I can't go to work. Do you
have the key?
[Music]
Dog If that's the case, it's my turn. Hey, I'll take care of it. Please open it. [Music] Looks like I don't have to worry about footsteps. You
don't have to worry about winter either.  Well, unless there's a hidden door
or a dead body is found outside, let's be
careful.Ah, there's
nothing special about that one.There's
someone who did that.We
can't let our guard down.
Music]
N
DET